[Music]
mkhd here all right
we've heard the rumblings it seems like
everyone's just saying it
so let's talk about it apple getting rid
of the port
in the next iphone see
all of the best and all of the worst
things about
apple products like the iphone come from
the level of control apple has over them
now if apple's trillion dollar value is
any clue you know for most people these
are typically good things like we were
just talking about this with the m1 max
and how this vertical integration is
what enables this amazing efficiency and
that kind of started in the iphones with
their great use of smaller batteries and
less ram and their excellent image and
video quality with their image
processing pipeline all the stuff that
people love about the iphone comes from
this but with all of that control
it also means if you're an apple person
you're along for the ride for the misses
too
now whether that's you know a ultra-thin
keyboard in the max that ends up
breaking after two years or just antena
gate or something bad about the iphone
you're along for the ride so now the
next thing for apple is getting rid of
the port on the iphone possibly as soon
as the next iphone lucky iphone 13
but there's no way they just get rid of
the port and don't say anything right
and that brings us to maybe one of the
truest most consistent facts in all of
tech which is that
most of apple reporting can be boiled
down to looking at the past looking at
what the history of one of the biggest
most consistent tech giants ever has
done
and applying that pattern to the future
assuming it will happen again assuming
they will keep that up so when i do that
when i look back at previous iphones as
they've moved towards this portless
future
i've noticed that with everything
they've removed from the iphone they
always do two things
one
they try to solve
the problem that is caused by the thing
they got rid of and probably charge you
for it
and two
they will always try to justify on stage
why they got rid of that thing
so solve
and justify so just look back at a few
years of the iphone through this lens
let's get rid of all the moving parts
iphone 10 they got rid of the beloved
home button right now you would have a
really hard time finding one reasonable
person who was like oh yeah get rid of
touch id get rid of the best fastest
like most perfect biometric
authentication we've ever seen in a
phone we don't really need the home
button anymore right
but apple had this vision of getting rid
of this button so they needed to solve
and justify so they did in fact solve no
touch id by adding this new thing called
face id so they're getting back this
form of biometric authentication
and they justified getting rid of it
because hey look at how much more screen
you get look at how great this
bezel-less thing looks the gestures are
great and this is the future of the
iphone and so you could still buy an
iphone with a home button the iphone 8
which was launched or at least announced
on the same day but it was very clear
from that moment forward that that was
the future of the iphone so here's
another one remember when they wanted to
get rid of the headphone jack in the
iphone
same thing
solve and justify
now this time this was in 2016 and it
was a little bit more of a notoriously
less convincing solve and justify but
they tried it they solved no headphone
jack by releasing and selling their own
wireless headphones the same day they
called them air pods and they turned out
to be kind of a ridiculously popular
product that made apple a lot of money
and then they went to justify on stage
getting rid of the headphone jack with a
couple of things this was the iphone 7
we're talking about and so this actually
became the first water and dust
resistant iphone i had to go back and
watch the presentation again to remember
that but the thing is there were also
already phones out there with water
resistance and headphone jacks already
so they had to toss in a little extra uh
they had more space inside the phone now
for a better taptic engine and a
slightly bigger battery
sure i guess
and they also tossed out this whole
courage thing that went over great uh
they had the courage to move forward
towards this wireless future
okay so what's next
the lightning port they want to get rid
of that too so the question is now
what's going to be their solve and
justify what's going to be their
solution to getting rid of the lightning
port and what's going to be their reason
that they tell us for getting rid of the
lightning port so i spoke to mark german
about this probably the most reliable
apple journalist on planet earth right
now
just about when and why they would do
this pardon the quality it is from a
macbook webcam what do you think could
possibly be apple's uh explanation or
angle to justify or explain why they
wanted to get rid of the port the last
piece you could plug in yeah you know i
think that their explanation for moving
the charging port is going to probably
be nearly identical to their explanation
for removing the headphone jack their
rationale is probably going to be the
same one you don't need it two we have
wireless three it takes up you know
valuable space that they can use for
other things whether that's making a
larger battery
or other little gizmos they can throw in
there right
i mean this is what would make sense to
me so my sense is that they're going to
add in screen fingerprint whether that's
the 21 phone or the 22 phone that
probably you know i'm not exactly sure
but i assume that's going to take up a
little bit more space inside the phone
to have that sensor underneath the
display right so i would say you know
what they'll probably be like this is
the trade-off we're gonna remove that
pork that you probably don't use or need
anyways and we're going to put it put
that under screen fingerprint a larger
battery better camera et cetera et
cetera okay so they add an in-screen
fingerprint reader to the phone the same
year that they get rid of the port maybe
so they can say the extra space from
getting rid of the port allowed room for
those internals
maybe that's not technically wrong but
okay maybe a little extra water
resistance and boom that can be apple's
justification
for getting rid of the port sure but i
think the solve part
is much harder here it's why it seems to
us logically like removing the port is
ridiculous like it's it's the most
necessary part of
every phone in history is already had
ports
but here's how i think apple can frame
it so number one they'll say we solved
it with this whole magsafe thing and now
we've got this amazing wireless charging
solution that slaps onto the back of the
phone it's perfect it's amazing and
number two when's the last time you
plugged in your phone for anything other
than charging and what really is going
to need to happen to be honest with you
is they can't pull this off unless they
put the bag safe in the box right at
forty dollars this year i'm sure they
can get the margins down at higher
quantities too being able to feasibly
price it at twenty or thirty dollars but
i think you know time allows for for
stronger margins on these products and
time allows for lower prices so i think
we'll all even out trust me if they move
to a portless iphone and don't include
the mag safe on the box
you know i'm going to lose my mind on
twitter right so you know that would be
that would be pretty controversial and
yeah i would be shocked if they did that
but on the other hand you know they're
the same company that said they're
moving away for environmental reasons
this year but really requires you to go
ahead and buy
uh that new charger for you know 40 or
60 dollars depending if you get the mag
safe as well to really take full
advantage of that full power charging so
i guess anything's possible so i agree
with mark i think magsafe kind of has to
be in the box logically but little known
fact do you know how the apple watch
also ships with that little puck as
their own little mag safe there's two
versions of that there's actually a
plastic and metal version of that little
puck charger depending on which apple
watch you get you might get either the
plastic cheaper one or the metal more
expensive one right now the only magsafe
available for the iphone the one they've
just invented is a metal one and so i
could easily see apple making a new
plastic version
around next year or sometime between now
and then which will be cheaper allowing
them to toss it in the box and also save
a little money now there are some other
uses of the port on the iphone
specifically things like
transferring data when you're setting up
a new iphone or
wired car play for the 99 of cars that
don't have wireless car
but again if you look at the grand
scheme of things apple's gonna say those
are more niche things and they can
dedicate teams of people to solve those
problems like starting a while ago so
they can make maybe a lightning adapter
for wireless carplay they can make maybe
a perfected wireless iphone setup i
already use iphone setup wirelessly when
i'm transferring my data for an old one
so they can work on that stuff between
now and the next iphone and then they'll
have their solution they will have their
solve
and their justify what's uh what's next
then if they've gotten rid of the home
button they've gotten rid of the
headphone jack they're getting rid of
the port
are the buttons next
oof
that's a good one i don't see how they
can remove the uh the buttons to be
honest i
i'm gonna go ahead and say the buttons i
think are here to stay for at least a
couple more years just because
buttons are just such a difficult thing
to solve
and really difficult to justify getting
rid of and actually as a matter of fact
replacing the buttons on the side of a
phone with this pressure sensitivity and
haptive feedback has been done before
and it wasn't great i reviewed the htc
u12 plus in 2018 which did exactly this
and maybe the tech and the sensors and
haptic motors is better since then you
know maybe you could remove accidental
presses and even the weird glitches and
customization and do it all better with
today's tech but even then it's like i
can't help but think what if the phone
freezes you know you already can't yank
the battery but now you also can't like
hard reset with the buttons because the
buttons are frozen like buttons
buttons the way they are are pretty
great i there's not a whole lot you can
improve about them and i think getting
rid of them for the tiny tiny little bit
of extra space you might gain or maybe
some better water resistance it's just a
really tough sell so i think buttons are
here for a while but again
it's not if
it's when will they eventually get
around to changing that too fun fact
though there is actually already a
completely buttonless holeless
phone did you hear about this it's been
tried before last year in 2019 along
came the meizu zero this phone had no
charging port no speaker holes
no physical buttons and no headphone
jack so we've had a completely holeless
phone before how did it go well they got
their headlines for sure got a lot of
people talking about it and then meizu
made the phone an indiegogo project it
got a grand total of 39 backers failed
to meet its funding goal
and died
cancelled so the world wasn't really
ready for that yet maybe someday we'll
look back and say that was ahead of its
time that this whole meizu zero thing it
was just ahead of the tech available to
it but at the end of the day i want to
pass the question off to you philip
defranco style where do you fall on this
whole
port thing if apple gets rid of the port
in the next iphone
will you just be right up in line
getting it and just switching to magsafe
and calling it a day or will you be on
the other side of that spectrum raging
in the comments about how apple created
a problem and then solved it and
conveniently sold you the solution again
i'm curious i'm sure there'll be a lot
of good comments below and then how do
you feel about this whole buttonless
portless future that we're moving
towards because again it's apple's
starting the trend but as we've seen so
often maybe one or two years after apple
does something ridiculous like getting
rid of the headphone jack
it usually ends up becoming a trend and
we start to see it everywhere so let me
know if you're on board with the whole
thing or if you hate the idea we'll hang
out in the comment section below and i
think it'll be pretty good either way
thanks for watching if you want to
listen to my entire conversation with
mark it'll be on the next waveform
episode so definitely subscribe to our
podcast if you haven't already to check
that and i'll catch you guys in the next
video
peace